Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Sister Location Custom Night.
Now, we got Freddy & Co. here, and I've kinda devised a little bit of a strategy.
See, Funtime Freddy, you don't actually need to see where he goes.
You only need to listen where he's moving, and then, if he says he's got a surprise, do the opposite door.
If he sends Bon-Bon, do the same door.
And so, that's pretty easy to solve. You don't need to waste any power with that.
The only thing you actually need to check on is Funtime Foxy.
Just like Foxy was in the original game.
And I'm assuming since there's a lot of door-banging, that's
probably not going to consume power like it did in the first game, but I can't be guaranteed about that.
I gotta find out about that.
And, then, just Yenndo is just a quick flip of the monitor.
So, mostly, I just need to get good at the hotkeys to do all this stuff,
so that *I* can be even faster than trying to flip around
because in the future, I'm gonna need these hotkeys.
He's on the right.
[Funtime Freddy: Well, hello ag-gain!]
Mark: HIIIIII!
[Funtime Freddy: Are you ready for round two?] *Mark closes and opens door*
Mark: No!
Funtime Freddy: Get ready for a ~surprise~!
Mark: Oh, woah! Woaah ya-yehyoijoy-
*Bon-Bon Screeches*
AH! FUCKING FUCK!
Alright! Well, I got caught with my dick out!
Fuuck me, then!
Alright, so that didn't go as planned.
I went in with a plan, I came out with *in a low whisper* shit in my pants.
I'm gonna try that again. That was embarrassing.
That was bad. Just plain old bad.
We're not even going to talk about that.
That was bad.
See, I wasn't listening. I was busy BLABBING MY MOUTH!
You're on the right!
[Funtime Freddy: Well, hello again!] Mark: Hey. *Freddy cackles*
Hello!
[Funtime Freddy: Are you ready for round two?]
Mark: No!
Hello [Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon, let's not keep our friend waiting!]
Mark: Was that you on the left?
[Funtime Freddy: Hey, Bon-Bon! Go ge-get him!]
Mark: Oh. Oh! That was it.
[Funtime Freddy: Ready or not, here I come!]
Mark: Okay.
No, that wasn't it.
[Funtime Freddy: Get ready for a ~surprise~!]
Mark: NoooOOoo~!
[Funtime Freddy: Oh Birthday Boy~!]
Mark: Aha! I got your number now!
What are you gonna do? Huh?!
[Funtime Freddy: Anybody home?]
Mark: NO!
Woah! Hello.
[Funtime Freddy: Hey, Bon-Bon, go g-get him!]
Mark: Agh!
Okay, no, don't do that!
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon, let's not keep our friend wa-aiting!]
Mark: Whoa, whoa!
Okay, no!
I'm okay!
Jeezums.
That takes the oxygen down real quick.
[Funtime Freddy: Ready or n-not, here I come!]
Mark: Yeh, what are you doing?
Ooh, that's not good.
Okay.
Hey!
Don't do that!
Stop! God dammit!
[Funtime Freddy: Oh, Birthday Boy!]
Mark: My oxygen flow is going bad!
[Bonnet giggles]
Woah, hey, STOP!
[Funtime Freddy: Get ready for a ~surprise~!]
Mark: No, I'm not!
[Small metallic knock of a metal bun just wanting a hug]
Haha, banged your nose on it.
Woah, fuck you.
[Funtime Freddy: Anybody home?]
Mark: Fuck, man, Yondee? Yondu?
Yondu drops your oxygen like a bastard.
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon, let's not keep our friend waiting!]
Mark: L-Let's not!
Do- [Freddy: Hey, Bon-Bon,] *in an obnoxious voice that's trying to imitate Funtime Freddy* BON-BON! [Freddy: Go g-get 'em!]
*Again, in an obnoxious voice that's trying to imitate Funtime Freddy* WHAWH! GO GET HIM, BON-BON!
[Funtime Freddy: Ready or not] Oh, my God. [Here I come!]
Mark: That was so much spit.
Woah!
Do I get to see- woah.
Do I get to see Foxy running down the hall?
[Knocking]
Aw, dammit!
[Funtime Freddy: Oh, Birthday Boy!]
I'm- Imma find out if I can see Foxy running down that hall.
[Funtime Freddy: Knock-knock, is anybody home?]
Mark: NO!
*Once again, in an obnoxious voice that's trying to imitate Funtime Freddy* Is BON-BON HOME?!
NO!
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon] Bon-Bon [let's not keep our friend waiting!]
Mark: No, you shouldn't.
~Dick~.
Honk for luck! *Honk noise of reassurance*
Haha.
[Funtime Freddy: Ready or not, here I come!]
Mark: Well, that's not one of your things.
Oh, woah. I don- woah.
Woah, woah, woah.
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon] BON-BON. [Go get him!]
Mark: NO!
[Funtime Freddy: Oh, Birthday Boy!]
Mark (in falsetto): OH, BIRTHDAY BOY!
How about you shut up?
[Funtime Freddy: Hey, Bon-Bon. Go ge-get him!]
Mark: No.
Woah, woah.
[Funtime Freddy: Knock-knock, is] NO. [Anybody home?]
Mark: Nah, not really.
Woah, boink.
Okay. I wonder what happens if Bonnet goes all the way across the screen.
Oh, wait, it's probably death!
So, we're doing pretty bad, b-but we just crossed 4 a.m.
We technically could make it.
[Funtime Freddy: Oh, Birthday Boy!]
Mark: Just remembering by the other stuff that we've done in the past.
Ooh.
That's not good.
[Funtime Freddy: B-Bon-Bon, go get him!]
Mark: Oof. That sounded like double.
[Funtime Freddy: Hey, Bon-Bon, go ge-get him!]
Mark: Man, he's really freaking out by now.
[Funtime Freddy: Ready or not] Woah, woah. [Ready or not, here I come!]
Mark: Okay. I wonder if that has anything to do with the actual, like,
game or that's just bugging out like that.
I gotta ima-
[Funtime Freddy: Oh Birthday Boy~]
Mark: I gotta imagine that he's falling apart right now.
Woah, woah get ready- NO!
Not yet, not yet, not yet.
Not yet. I gotta WIN THIS!
[Funtime Freddy: Get ready for a ~surprise~!]
Mark: How 'bout no?
[sad thunk of poor Bon-Bon :( ]
[Funtime Freddy: Knock knock, is anybody home?]
Mark: NO!
Also no.
You'd think that you'd get the point that you're not welcome in here!
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon go get him!]
Mark: NO!
[Knocking]
[Bon-Bon attacks]
AH, FUCKING NO!!
OH, I THOUGHT THE KNOCK-
OH NO!  (づ´• ᗝ •`)づ
I LET HIM IN RIGHT AT THE FUCKING END! ᕕ(òᗝó)ᕗ
NO! I heard the KNOCK from FOXY!
Ohhhhhh noooOOOOOooo!
Awwhhhhhhhhhh...
Unless I misheard and he was on the other side,
but I don't think that was the case.
I think I was just TOO twitchy.
[sound of hair floofing]
Okay, but I almost had it, this is gonna be easy.
I got this. This is- I got it!
Everybody look out, I got it, I'm an expert at this.
Don't worry, I've got a lot of practice in failure.
So...
maybe I'll try success for once.
[Whispering] Gotta floof the hair!
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon go ge-get him]
Mark: Noooo!
[Funtime Freddy (singing): Oh Birthday Boy!]
[Whispering] Floof the hair.. for power!
Doing great on power!
Doing wonderfully, actually
[Funtime Freddy: Ready or Not! Here I come!]
Mark: Whoa- wai-
Fucking, fucking, fucking, fucking, fuck!
Oh Jeezums. Can you-
Was he running?
Woah, he- woah. That was- That was super weird.
That was like, super weird.
Oh man, that was weird.
He's on the right but I didn't forget about that.
He's on the right and he's trying to shtab meh
I wonder if they're-
Mark: Are they- are they still trying to stuff me in into an animatronic suit?
Or they doing that thing where they're- Ahh fuck you.
They're doing that thing where they're trying to scoop out my innards?
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon let's not keep our friend waiting!]
Mark: LET'S NYOOOT! BETTER NYOOOOT!
TIME FOR TEA AND CRUMPEEEHTS!
We're doing good! We're doing good. We're doing about as well as last time.
A few too many Foxy hits
[Funtime Freddy: Oh birthday boy!]
'Kay, he's on the right!
You're not gonna mix me up with all the sounds.
I know exactly where you iiiiiiis-zuh.
And imunna find ya till ya dead
I'm not used to these buttons yet. Having buttons to do this stuff is super convenient-
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon, let's not keep our friend wai-aiting!]
And it's probably an essential skill to be able to do this
But, I-, yeah, uh, my muscles are not ready for that. My muscles in this game are built for clicking
[Funtime Freddy: Ready or not, here I come!]]
And I am NOT 100% down with all of this
Man I got all- I got all kinds of kerfuckled.
It's probably a good strategy to just follow with the mouse-
[Funtime Freddy: Ready or not,  here I come!]
Mark: -where he is and leave it there. Whoa.
Unless you need to do that.
Jeez.
Because that way you have a physical indication of where he is without having to retain it in men- memory.
[Funtime Freddy: Oh, birthday boooooy~]
I have to flip over to the right if he's on the right
And flip over to the left if he's on the left.
But, if Ballora was here, that'd throw a wrench into the whole fucking plan.
Jeezums.
[Funtime Freddy: Knock knock!]
Mark: No!
[Funtime Freddy: Is anybody home?]
Mark: Woah no!
[Funtime Freddy: What a party pooper!]
Mark: Yaaaaaaaay~!
I almost fucked that up right at the end!
[singing] But! I~ Am~ Theeee best~ in the WORLD!
and I've got a great smile! :)
Do I get to go home and enjoy my exotic butters?
[Cheerful minigame music plays]
Oh boy.
[singing to the tune of the music] Hello everybody, here I am again! Mister Purple Guy~!
Lovin' life, livin life, not~ an~ animatronic at all!
Gonna murder some children because I gotta spread the disease of what the hell~ I~ am~.
Oh boy! It's time to go down the street~ pick up some groceries and maybe eat some meat
OH! I LOVE TO BE A KILLER ROBOT!
It's the best thing! [song ends]
I guess that was the end there.
I had some more lyrics to put in to that,
but, alas! I guess,
tha- that's what we're doing here.
Well, I just... I four-starred THAT
So I've got "Angry Ballet", "Freddy & Co.", and I'm gonna try "Funtime Frenzy".
Now the only difference here is that Foxy is much more aggressive and there's also the introduction of "Lolbit"
But it SEEMS that Yyyyyyenndo is actually going to be more forgiving than last time.
So, this shouldn't be too haaaaard!
Is that a good look for meee?
(In a lisp-y voice) Is this gonna be able to give me the power needed to surviiive?
I'll- [burps] I'll go for it.
Yeah, ya know- I can do this. I can do this. Okay, I can do this
There's still nothing that's been going in the vent.
And also, I've got hair in the middle of my... face to block out any possibility of me seeing this shit
[door closes and opens]
[Funtime Freddy: Well, hello agaaaain!]
Mark: Oh, fuck. L-O-L.
[Funtime Freddy: Are you re-eady for round two?]
You mean round three? You st- [Funtime Freddy: Hey, Bon-Bon, go get him!]
Mark: -ya stupid bear.
[Bon-Bon thunks on the door]
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon lets not keep our friend waiting!]
Mark: Whoa.
That's- that's har-
[Funtime Freddy: Get ready for a ~surprise!~]
Mark: Jeezums, okay.
[Knock]
[Funtime Freddy: Ready or not, here I come!]
Mark: This seems a lot harder!
[Funtime Freddy: Hey Bon-Bon go ge-get him!]
Mark: NO!
[Funtime Freddy: Oh, birthday booooy!
Mark: Okay. Eugh...
Man I do not like this. L-O-L.
No-no-no-no-no.
Oh, and Foxy's gonna come down,
but at least I'm gonna be able to see
IF Foxy bashes the door [Funtime Freddy: Anybody home?] and actually takes some power from me
Woah! Oh. Lol
LOL-eroni!
Okay.
Whew.
Man, I love havin' that button there
[Funtime Freddy: Get ready for a ~surprise~!]
Mark: How 'bout no?
[Bon Thunk™]
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon, let's not keep our friend waiting!]
[Knocking]
[Funtime Freddy: Hey Bon-Bon go get him!]
Mark: I-I don't know if that took any power?
It kinda jumped down a second? But it might have been-
[Funtime Freddy:Ready or not, here I come!]
Mark: -it might have been just because-
Oh, shit. Goddammit, I was not watching Foxy.
Ohhhh fuck you
Oh geez this is getting pretty stressful..
Okay I was not watching- [Funtime Freddy: (singing): Oh Birthday Boy!]
Oh boy. Fuck off LOL-eroni!
Alright..
Yeah, this is pretty stressful, it's actually hard to-
hard to concentrate and f-
[Funtime Freddy: Knock knock! Anybody home?]
-and focus on absolutely everything that I need to focus on.
but its a good thing that Yenndo is being a little more forgiving than he was last time,
but I'm doing very-
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon! Let's not-]
Mark: -not good on power.
[Funtime Freddy: Hey, Bon-Bon! Go ge-get him]
No.
Foxy seems to be doing pretty good
and we're kind of on target for power.
[Funtime Freddy: Get ready for a ~surprise~!]
Mark: We're just eating up a LITTLE more than I would like.
[Funtime Freddy: Oh birthday boy!]
Just a little bit more than I would like.
We're actually doing relatively okay.
If I can get thir- above thirty with 4 am left?
Mark: We'll be in golden shape.
[Funtime Freddy: Knock knock! Anybody home?]
Mark: Golden shape.
That's not a pun about Golden Freddy!
Who, I don't even know if is IN this game,
but there is "Golden Freddy" MODE.
Oh boy.
4 am, we're doing okay. We're actually doing REALLY good.
Like- actually we're doing REALLY good here.
[Funtime Freddy (singing) : Oh Birthday Boy!]
Mark: This is- this is actually ludicrously good.
So, Foxy must NOT..
take any power when he hits the door, because otherwise we would be in a much worse situation.
[Funtime Freddy: Knock knock. Is anybody home?] Mark: Although I'm keeping him locked down. Which is pretty good but,
and also the tracking method with the moving the camera-
Oh! Here he comes.
[Knocking]
[Funtime Freddy Get ready for a ~surprise~!]
Mark: Oh good! That's convenient; it's the same door that I ordinarily would.
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon, let's not keep our friend waiting!]
Mark: Yeah, you wouldn't want to do that.
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon go get him!]
Mark: Oh man, that buggin' out is definitely part of the experience here.
[Funtime Freddy: Ready or not! Here i come!] Mark: Lol-eroni. Okay. Man, harder to keep track.
And this is just with a few noise interruptions.
I DO NOT know if I'll be able to handle this with so many-
[Funtime Freddy: Get ready for a ~surprise~!]
-with so many pieces of noise- that's on the other side.
[Funtime Freddy: Oh Birthday Boy!]
Mark: Man. Oh man, a lot of things to juggle and there's only 3 animatronics or 4 I guess.
Oh boy. 5 a.m., twenty three- we're gonna win this.
[Funtime Freddy: Knock knock!]
Mark: I just gotta keep this up.
[Funtime Freddy: Is anybody home?]
Mark: I gotta keep this up. But this is good training
for going in to the future.
Man,  I love the fact that there's new stuff here.
This is, like, genuinely, really interesting new stuff that he's put in with a few extra pieces to the lore
and it kinda dives deeper in the mystery.
[Funtime Freddy: Hey Bon-Bon, go g-get 'em'!]
Mark: -of what this all is.
And that, that is really cool
The fact that that's all integrated in a cool, free DLC
And that's what I like about DLC; it should add to the experience of the game.
It doesn't HAVE to be free if it's enough, but the fact that this is free is, actually just, really cool.
[Funtime Freddy (singing): Oh Birthday Boy!]
Ugh, man. Enough kissin' Scott's ass
Alright, almost done.
Almost there.
Almost there!
[Funtime Freddy: Bon-Bon, go g-get 'em!]
Mark: No.
[Sad Bun Knock]
[Funtime Freddy: Knock knock! Is anybody home?]
Mark: Man. Figuring out the LOL, I need like a hotkey hacker keypad over here. On the right-hand side.
I need the mouse with, like, the whole keyboard on the si-
[Funtime Freddy: What a Party Pooper!]
Mark: YAAAAY!
[Shift Complete] Mark (singing to the tune):
~I did it! I have another song and I'm
dropping the octaves dooooooooownnn!~
[song ends]
Wow, that was terrible that was probably the worst song that I've done yet.
I'm gonna live with that now. [minigame music starts]
Okay, yup, here we go again.
Oh boy. Another day! It's so fun and free to be in the sun and walk on this sidewalk~
Looks like my skin is a little more pale than it was before.
That guy doesn't trust me!
It's a little odd that my skin is rotting off!
What the fuck am I doing?
All my neighbors hate me! But...
(normal voice) There we go. Oh, man.
That is moderately concerning. Because, yeah, that guy definitely did -uh- question that whole experience there.
So, that is actually all the time I have for this particular episode of Five Nights at Freddy's Sister location Custom night
We've got "Dolls, Attack!", "Girls' Night",  "Weirdos",
"Top Shelf", "Bottom Shelf",  "Cupcake [Challenge]" , and
"Golden Freddy" left which means that we got
One, two, three, four, five, six... seven.
It's gonna be a long haul but I'm ready for it.
This is GOOD, because
I need to get accustomed to every single element individually and know how they work on a basic level before I can layer them all.
But, I'm starting to piece together a general  strategy it all probably will revolve around fine-tuning the exact moment when ballora comes close to the door
other than anything else, in addition to the people in the vent which are likely to be the little dolls.
Not the Minireenas! I'm talking about the Bibbity-Babbity-Electro Babbies, which are gonna be bad.
But either way, thank you everybody so much for watching.
Hope you enjoyed this. Let me know what you thought down in the comments below!
And as always, I will see you... In the next video. Buh bye!
[Horror outro plays]
['Haunted' outro plays for the rest of the video]
(Remember to thank the caption editors for the wonderful captions! Credits in the description!)
(Have a wonderful day/night!)